mein aufreger des tages ist heute
deutschlands aktuell für mich unfähigste
ministerin unsere
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht ich möchte jetzt nicht schon
wieder von den helm anfangen das ist
etwas weiter zurückgehen auch wenn
kompetenz bei der vergabe von
ministerposten deutschen politikbetrieb
der leider sowieso eher nebensächlich
ist ist es doch etwas besonderes wie
wenig geeignet frau lambrecht auch
außerhalb der helme wurde das
verteidigungsministerium ist ihre
minister karriere begann im
justizministerium wo sie besonders mit
fragwürdigen beförderung von
parteifreund für aufsehen sorgte laut
einem tagesschau bericht soll sie gut
zuhören angeblich 16 personen befördert
haben bis ihr parteifreund person nummer
17 von der qualifikation her endlich an
der reihe war sein spitzname soll
seitdem gewesen sein nummer 17 nach
ihrer zeit im justizministerium wollte
sie dann eigentlich wieder mit der
politik aufhören und als juristin
arbeiten doch so viel glück hatte
deutschland leider nicht olaf scholz
machte sie zur verteidigungsministerin
und verpasste meiner meinung nach damit
die chance auf eine fähige führung der
bundeswehr die süddeutsche zeitung
berichtete dazu die ersten tage
ministerium begann frostig die alte
führungsmannschaft wurde sofort kalt
gestellt insgesamt scheint lambrecht
eine aversion gegen alles militärische
zu haben mit der aufgabe sich dienst
gerade zu merken schienen sie sichtlich
überfordert und nach berichten von
business insider prüft ihr sie sogar den
generalinspekteur aus ihrem begriff
beraterkreis zu entfernen ich finde die
bundeswehr braucht endlich jemanden
expertise der dieser aufgabe gewachsen
ist und ja auch jemand der schon mal an
der waffe gedient hat
dem kann ich dir nur zustimmen
grundsätzlich sollte man immer im
unternehmertum eine kompetenz mit mit
sich bringen und auch daraus resultieren
wird man bewertet ich denke
verteidigungsministerium ist eine der
einzigen ministerien wo man zwingend
eine erfahrung mitbringen sollte
eigentlich auch im
gesundheitsministerium
da ist aber zeigt man eine separate
debatte zu führen weil da sag ich mal
der lauterbach ist ja mit dem 10
vielleicht zu arg
spezifisch ausgerichtet deshalb ja aber
grundsätzlich stimme ich ihm zu man
sollte auf jeden fall dienst an der
waffe oder den wehrdienst gemacht haben
um den anforderungen eines ministeriums
entsprechen zu können ich glaube das ist
ein ergebnis der falsch verstandenen
quoten politik der spd und auch der cdu
inzwischen das ist ja inzwischen schon
die dritte frau die auf diesem stuhl
sitzt im verteidigungsministerium alle
drei haben einen scherbenhaufen
hinterlassen begann mit ursula von der
leyen die eigentlichen intelligente
politikern ist aber auch keinen zugang
zu dem thema hatte und dass angela
merkel kanzlerin war in den letzten
jahren hat auch damit zu tun in welchem
zustand wir heute die bundeswehr
vorfinden wenn frau longa v lambrecht
wäre ja nicht auf diesen stuhl gekommen
wenn die spd nicht sich im zwang gesehen
hätte
halbe-halbe männern frauen auf
ministerposten zu erheben wenn lars
klingbeil
verteidigungsminister geworden wäre was
ich mir gewünscht hatte persönlicher
dienst eine waffe ziehen da auch nicht
gehalt ist trotzdem der hat aber im
verteidigungsausschuss der hat sich mit
den themen ständig beschäftigt er kommt
aus einer soldaten familie der schon als
jugendlicher da aufgewachsen dem milieu
wenn der klingbeil minister geworden
wäre wäre uns auch karl lauterbach
erspart geblieben als
gesundheitsminister welche freude müsste
man heute sagen weil der ferne frau
gesundheitsministerin geworden wer immer
das gewesen wäre das wären auf jeden
fall besser gewesen als lauterbach finde
ich auf jeden fall vor allem viel mehr
wertschätzung für unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten und die bundeswehr weil was uns
jetzt bevorsteht es ja wirklich
weiterhin die debatte manche fangen da
ja schon wieder zu zweifeln an daran
dass die sondervermögen wichtig und
richtig ist für die bundeswehr es geht
nicht um aufrüstung es geht überhaupt
warum ausrüsten dass unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten angemessen ihre aufgabe
wahrnehmen können ich glaube da haben
wir noch viel zu tun dass wir richtige
wehrhaftigkeit nicht verwechseln mit
militarismus
sondern wissen wir brauchen eine
wehrhafte bundeswehr um unsere freiheit
um den frieden zu verteilen frau
teuteberg hat er jedes recht das
verteidigungsministerium entboten
ministerium ist die es mir schon
ich glaube das gilt für verschiedene
positionen und auch so normal und ich
bin auch nicht so der meinung dass
politiker fachleute sein müssen aber sie
müssen sie müssen durchsetzungsfähig
sein glaubt sie müssen guten überblick
haben da ist eigentlich das was frau
lambrecht mit print juristin gar nicht
so schlecht man muss sich nämlich auch
nicht von beamten erzählen lassen was
geht oder was nicht geht aber am ende
ist das keine fachspezifische frage ist
eine frage glaube ich gilt der der
erfahrungen der herangehensweise einen
guten überblick zu haben
durchsetzungsfähig zu sein stimmt das
braucht die bundeswehr besonders bei
jungtieren prinzip hat frau lambrecht
alles nicht was ich jetzt aufgezählt
haben und das ja munter sie haben zwar
jetzt begonnen hat die verwendung der
100 milliarden für die rüstungsprojekte
der bundeswehr selbst in die hand zu
nehmen mit dem generalinspekteur darüber
zu reden da sitzt frau lambrecht mit
dabei muss ja wohl auch aber er hat doch
selbst in die hand genommen hat
natürlich auch damit zu tun wie er seine
eigene verteidigungsministerin
einschätzt da kann ja viel mal vom brett
rutschen das sind von den 100 milliarden
schnell mal 50 weg und man weiß gar
nicht wohin also da muss man sehr
aufpassen
auch das ist übrigens du hast eine menge
von fehlleistungen aufgezählt dass die
ministerin nicht mal einen ansatz
unternommen hat eine gruppe von
kompetenten leuten zusammen zu rufen die
den auftrag haben die verwendung der
hunde und das militärische sein und
konnten sich nicht mehr als die ganze ja
aber das hat wahrscheinlich auch der
grund dass deutschland sowieso in den
letzten jahren sich sehr pazifistisch
aufgestellt hat immer wenn es mehr
waffen und dann war man ja ganz ein ganz
böser mensch und man sagt dann ja auch
ja frauen die sind gerade in dem bereich
ja viel besser weil die reden die
greifen nicht gleich zur waffe diese
entwicklung nannte das nennt sich
feministische außenpolitik
ich glaube das hat uns in den
vergangenen jahren sehr verfolgt und
diese üble rechnung müssen wir jetzt
einfach bezahlen dass wir uns einfach zu
sehr auf den frieden vertraut haben und
gemeint haben wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass der frieden erhalten bleibt indem
wir reden
wir haben ja vieles falsch verstanden
auch gedacht dass wir von russland
abhängig sind ist nur gut für uns ja die
russen liefern zuverlässig ja das tun
sie schon aber von wem kriegt man das
zeug jetzt vor also haben denn ihr
wirtschaft nicht mit den großen zusammen
ab dann sind sie auch wirtschaftlich von
uns abhängig und deswegen lassen sie uns
wert sogar gleich reden
diplomatie ist gut aber man muss
natürlich ernst genommen werden damit
das was bringt und dafür muss man so
stark sein dass für die andere seite
nicht verhandeln keine option ist und
das ist vernachlässigt worden ja ich
glaube darüber brauchen wir noch eine
echte debatte da gibt es noch einige die
noch nicht so weit sind dass wir jetzt
wirklich ganz konsequent die bundeswehr
so ausstatten und nicht schon wieder
überlegen wie können wir das für
irgendwelche anderen zwecke noch ein
bisschen verteilt wobei ich nur
einschränken wenn das sag ich mal
niemand ist davon ausgegangen dass jetzt
hier ein angriffskrieg aus russland
ausgeht und dass die bundeswehr jetzt so
explizit im fokus gerät ja man ging er
davon aus es läuft immer so da war die
vorgängerin war ja auch eine frau da war
auch erfahrung der bundeswehr auf jeden
fall beliebter gewesen sein also ich hab
mir mal frau kramp karrenbauer ehrlich
gesagt bei manchen bundeswehrsoldaten
sehr gutes gehört da habe ich etwas
anderes bild auf gespiegelt bekommt
schon einzeln auch vom
bundestagsabgeordneten
die sollen nicht ganz so daneben er wohl
gewesen wollte ja auch manches
beschaffen wo andrea gegen gewährte ja
gehört jetzt zur realität der jahre dazu
das nicht wenig blockiert wurde auch was
die ausrüstung gehört sicher auch gern
generalinspekteur geholt auch aus dem
saarland wie sie selber und ich weiß bin
nicht so sicher ob das und das richtige
merkmal war um ein generalinspekteur
auszuzeichnen und das aus dem saarland
kommt aber manchmal vertrag meine in der
razzia land ist keine besondere
militärmacht niemals gewesen in
ostdeutschland haben wir besondere
stimmt vielleicht sollte man auch über
die rolle der unserer soldaten mal
quartieren weil wenn zum beispiel so
etwas wie hochwasser oder erd- nehmen
oder andere katastrophen passieren warum
dauert es dann so lange bis die ins boot
holen kann damit die einen helfen als
wenn es schon nicht im krieg ziehen so
eine habe ja so viel gemacht die letzten
jahre ist ja eher so dass viele sich
daran gewöhnt haben immer nach der
bundeswehr zu rufen frau gefahr auch
hier in berlin jetzt beim thema
flüchtlinge jetzt umso wichtiger ist
dass wir in erinnerung rufen auch da
leistet die bundeswehr viel aber es ist
nicht ihr kernauftrag und wir müssen sie
jetzt mal ihren kernauftrag erfüllen
lassen und dafür richtig ausstatten sie
wird gerne bei katastrophenschutz bei
irgendwelchen personal knappheiten auf
das impfen und so genutzt kost nix aber
wir brauchen sie natürlich für ihren
kernauftrag ja ich wollte noch 12 quoten
frage sagen ich bin sehr dafür quoten
anzulegen bei der auswahl von
mandatsträgerinnen und mandatsträger
also bei bundestagsabgeordneten
kandidaten für parlamente bei ämtern bin
ich ganz anderer meinung da bin ich der
meinung da kommt es auf qualifikationen
an da sollten die bewerber schon mal was
mit dem thema zu tun gehabt haben und
nicht nach wie vor ist als man sollte
die quote von unten ansetzen jahren sie
irgendwann oben ankommt maler melden
müssen unterbesetzt seien aber bei den
ämtern es ist eine andere frage man muss
jemanden finden im
verteidigungsministerium der schon mal
mit der bundeswehr zu tun hatte davon
was versteht der auch mal eine waffe in
der hand hatte möglicherweise auf
jedenfalls der nicht völlig neu lernen
muss aber die frage ist ja schon bei der
quoten sache die du gerade angesprochen
hast es gibt ja die theorie dass man
unten anfangen muss auch im unternehmen
also dass man anfangen sollte ab dem
niedrigsten level damit es sich dann
hochziehen kann und dann oben die
leistungsträger beide geschlechter haben
und er ist eine quote oben nichts
bringen würde
dort könnte man denn da nicht ist
natürlich mich oft gefragt die frage
würde ich gerne eine frau teuteberg
spielen als politikerin warum gibt es
nicht in jedem wirtschaftsunternehmen
gibt es ein anforderungsprofil also ich
kann jetzt nicht hochgehen zu herr bode
und sagen so ich bin eine frau ich
möchte jetzt gerne chefredakteurin
werden war zwar erst 2017 im wollen
thalia aber ich wäre es jetzt gerne
schon mal also wieso gibt es kein
anforderungsprofil wie in jedem
wirtschaftsunternehmen auch für die
politik das habe ich mich immer gefragt
zb verteidigungsministerium warum muss
ist nicht jemand sein trotz vorgemacht
in kanada er hat ja sein kabinett damals
so aufgestellt dass sie auch vorfahren
haben warum gibt es nicht wie so ein
bewerbungsbogen wo man ein paar
fähigkeiten haben mussten
die politik hat eigene gesetze und
logischen wobei ehrlich gesagt bei denen
die als kanzler oder kanzlerin so der
regierungschefs
besetzen können wenn sie dann nehmen die
können natürlich trotzdem sind vor den
kriterien anlegen aber ansonsten ist es
natürlich so in parteien und in vielen
bereichen dass sie aus ehrenamt das ist
im ehrenamt geht und dass sie erstmal
sehen müssen welche menschen engagieren
sich und wer will denn für etwas
kandidieren oder verantwortung
übernehmen also sie haben auch nicht wie
in der wirtschaft natürlich die üblichen
möglichkeiten über gehalt und andere
dinge menschen zu fördern oder leistung
zu belohnen oder schlechtleistung zu
bestrafen also da gibt es viele gründe
aber wenn es um ämter geht um
regierungsämter hat das natürlich viel
mit der person zu tun die entscheiden
werde ja auch entscheidungsträger wollen
sich gerne die handlungsfähigkeit
erhalten und möglichst wenig kriterien
haben die ihnen die handlungsfähigkeit
einschränken deshalb wird es wieder das
erlebt haben bei olaf scholz bis zum
letzten moment hin und her geschubst und
dann war die frage also
lauterbach wird gesundheitsminister da
muss eine frau verteidigung machen da
sitzen wir jetzt gar in diesem loch
sitzen wir jetzt und zwar sind sie in
wahrheit zwei löcher ja ja das war uns
ganz wichtig noch mal mit der quote
führung aufzuschließen die landrechte
bald